well my friends joe biden is doing it
joe biden will be canceling up to 20 000
in student loan debt for those making
under 125 000 it'll be 10 000
for most folks but there's a pell grant
element to it which could raise that to
twenty thousand dollars we're going to
look at the details and i have to tell
you producer pat was completely correct
in his prediction producer pat has been
predicting on the award-winning bonus
show
that at a time
advantageous to democrats for the
midterm elections
joe biden would do some larger student
loan forgiveness than he has done so far
now remember that joe biden is already
done even before this more student loan
forgiveness than any other president and
we've covered that before
and pat said it's going to be close-ish
to the november midterms joe biden's
going to do something and i just didn't
think he was and here we are producer
pat completely correct new york times
reporting biden to cancel ten thousand
dollars in student debt
low income students are eligible for
more
uh the plan would be
ten thousand dollars in cancellation for
those earning under a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars a year and twenty
thousand dollars for those who received
pell grants for low income families now
the debt forgiveness is less than what
some democrats have been pushing for and
we will talk about that
biden also announced that a pandemic era
pause on student loan payments
which has been in effect since march of
2020 will expire at the end of the year
there is not yet an application process
this has been a big question okay so how
do how do we get the forgiveness if we
qualify what's the process that process
has not yet been made specific
a couple of other important notes here
students who receive pell grants will be
able to get up to 20 000 in forgiveness
about 60 percent of borrowers have pell
grants and the majority come from
families earning under thirty thousand
dollars a year the education department
estimates 27 million borrowers will
qualify for up to 20 000 in relief then
you've got millions more who will be
able to get the 10 000
and uh there are a number of other
repayment uh modifications that are
being made as well so let's go through
some of the different
reactions to this and then we're going
to delve further into it so one reaction
is this is not enough 10 000 is not
enough 20 000 is not enough fine
fine but this is already
overwhelmingly more than any other
president has done by far so as i've
said before
i tend to evaluate presidents based on
what they do
generally speaking and also for things
they promised to do
but don't do i think both are fair game
just saying well this president's bad
because he didn't do these ten things
that he never promised to do
that seems to be a way to end up
with relatively meaningless evaluations
of presidents so
when you look at what joe biden has done
he has by far for given more student
that than any other president um
counterpoint joe biden's only doing this
to help democrats in november well i
mean listen everything politicians do to
some degree is to help themselves is it
also good for people and the answer is
this is very good for people and there
are also some new rules for income-based
repayment plans which are arguably as
big of a deal as the forgiveness
repayment will be capped at five percent
of discretionary income rather than ten
that's a big source of relief your
payments are zero
if you are below 225 of the federal
poverty line uh due to an increase in
the non-discretionary fraction of income
unpaid interest is waived as long as
you're making monthly payments even if
the payments uh are zero based on those
earlier guidelines that i mentioned and
that's really a game changer
many people
are much more able to pay off a debt
if they're not accumulating and accruing
more and more and more interest through
the payment process
and that's a really big deal and then
forgiveness after ten years on loans
under twelve thousand dollars rather
than only twenty thousand dollars
uh which is uh another interesting
provision so there is a significant
amount of relief here in addition to the
forgiveness component for lower and
middle income borrowers and that's a
really really big deal now one question
is what does this do in terms of
democrat chances
going into the november midterms as we
have talked about before
right now in the house of
representatives i'm sorry in the senate
the odds for democrats have crept up
from a 52 shot at holding the senate to
55 high 50s
60 and now 64
right now the 538 estimate the forecast
is that democrats have a 64 chance of
retaining control of the senate we will
see whether that number increases on the
basis of this announcement from joe
biden in terms of the house of
representatives well republicans are
still favored to hold but by a smaller
uh
margin
than at any previous point during this
cycle right now republicans are down to
a 78 chance of taking the house of
representatives democrats at 22 still
the most likely outcome is democrats
keep the senate but lose the house but
the house numbers are looking it's hard
to call them good for democrats but they
are looking the least bad that they have
looked since we've started following
this election cycle so this is another
major major accomplishment by joe biden
later on in the show i am going to now
compare and contrast
the 180 that has taken place for the
biden administration which is which is
truly remarkable i mean if you look at
the biden administration two months ago
and now
it is truly stunning the change that we
have seen we're going to talk about that
and we're going to contrast that with
what's going on on the republican side
including a growing civil war wherein
former president donald trump is calling
for the removal of mitch mcconnell as
the senate minority leader it could not
be a greater contrast than what we are
seeing that'll come up a little bit
later
the david pakman shows longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time but
there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 percent off a
premium subscription at blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below